[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
Barbara halweg und mit Rudi Cerne guten
Abend spannender fußballkrimi heute
wieder ja bei der WM ein großer Favorit
ist ausgeschieden guten Abend
das ist eines unserer Themen von heute
Rückstand bei der Digitalisierung die
Bundesregierung will Deutschland in die
Top 10 Europas bringen
mit
250 Kilometern pro Stunde über die
Schwäbische Alb nach 10 Jahren Bauzeit
eröffnet die Bahn die neue Strecke
zwischen Ulm und Wendlingen
und Kroatien schlägt Brasilien nach
Elfmeterschießen und zieht als erste
Mannschaft ins Halbfinale der Fußball-WM
in Katar ein
[Musik]
im Fußball gehörte Deutschland zumindest
mal zur Weltspitze bei der
Digitalisierung hinken wir schon immer
hinterher das weiß auch der zuständige
Minister Wissing auf dem digitalgipfel
sagte er heute wir müssen die ewige
Bedenkenträgerei überwinden und einfach
schneller werden
dass das geht machen andere Länder vor
südkorea hat im Mobilfunk flächendeckend
5g und das seit 2019 Schweden hat im
Gesundheitsbereich die digitale
Patientenakte seit 2012 und in Estland
muss man nicht mehr zum Amt 99% der
Verwaltungsakte gehen digital wie
Deutschland sich jetzt aufstellen will
berichtet Roman leskova den
Personalausweis gibt's hierzulande
weiter nur im Kartenformat eine Variante
nur für Smartphone Fehlanzeige an den
Schulen zeigte die Pandemie vor welchen
Herausforderungen der digitalunterricht
steht und wer hoffte ein Rezept beim
Arzt überall gleich aufs Handy zu
bekommen guckt ebenso in die Röhre die
ihre Rezept Pilotregion stoppte gerade
die flächendeckende Einführung für
Ärztevertreter das Verfahren schlicht zu
kompliziert das funktioniert nicht weil
beispielsweise Karten nicht da sind Pins
nicht vorhanden sind und insofern muss
man sagen steht das schon ein bisschen
für die Digitalisierung Gesundheitswesen
im EU-weiten Ranking liegen beim Thema
Digitalisierung insgesamt Finnland und
Dänemark vorn Deutschland landet nur auf
Rang 13 damit es besser wird startete
der digitalminister im Sommer seine
digitalstrategie 18 Leuchtturmprojekte
und Zielvorgaben so soll bis 2025 etwa
die Hälfte aller stationären Anschlüsse
am Glasfasernetz angeschlossen sein die
umfassende Digitalisierung der
Verwaltung ein weiteres Ziel der
Behördengang online statt wie heute mit
Termin und Wartezeit auf dem Digital
Gipfel erklärte Wissing heute
Deutschland wolle bei der
Digitalisierung in die Top Ten der EU
dabei helfen solle künftig auch ein
Beirat er unterstützt die Ressource
dabei Schwerpunkt Vorhaben umzusetzen
schaut uns über die Schulter Schulter
konstruktiv gibt uns Hinweise wo wir
nicht schnell genug sind und schneller
werden können doch aus der
Zivilgesellschaft gibt es Kritik gerade
beim Thema Glasfaserausbau und digitaler
Verwaltung bleibe man skeptisch in
beiden Disziplin sind wir sehr schlecht
und haben eigentlich seit vielen Jahren
nur Durchhalteparolen ich kann trotzdem
heute kaum eine igament Anwendung online
machen trotzdem gibt es bereits
Verbesserungen manche sind klein und
ausgerechnet durch die Pandemie forciert
worden Videokonferenzen gehören in
vielen Unternehmen mittlerweile zum
Alltag zudem wurde erstmals in mehr als
der Hälfte aller Firmen weniger Papier
bedruckt als im Vorjahr
Theo Colin Berlin warum hängt
Deutschland da immer noch so hinterher
das steht doch seit Jahren schon auf der
politischen Agenda also eine der
plausibelsten und auch selbstkritischen
Antworten kommt aus der Wirtschaft wir
waren schlicht zu lange erfolgreich im
analogen Auto und Maschinenbau
beispielsweise brummt noch ohne massive
Digitalisierung warum also etwas ändern
anderen Orts wurde dagegen ja früher und
viel breiter auf digitale Industrie
gesetzt und aus der Bundesregierung kam
der nötige Druck schon gar nicht Angela
Merkel hat ja das Internet als Neuland
für uns alle bezeichnet und das ist
keine zehn Jahre her außerdem sind wir
als Gesellschaft offensichtlich zu
bürokratisch wir sind immer noch
papierverschwendungsweltmeister auch in
der Verwaltung Daten werden wir uns ja
zurecht gesellschaftlich geschützt aber
sie werden gleichzeitig zu wenig genutzt
sei es für vernetzte Produktion oder für
digitale Dienstleistung das ist ja
zuletzt allen klar geworden in der
Pandemie als ja
digitaler Unterricht kaum möglich war
und erst gestern haben die
Ministerpräsidenten eigentlich politisch
blank gezogen sie können die 200 Euro
Winterhilfe für Studenten nicht
auszahlen unter anderem wegen fehlender
Daten heute hieß es wir brauchen auch
eine digitale Zeitenwende aber wie
gesagt das gilt im Grunde schon seit
langem Dankeschön für diese Einschätzung
theokol war das aus Berlin
[Applaus]
auch bei der Bildung hat Deutschland
Nachholbedarf viele Grundschulkinder
hier lernen nicht mehr richtig lesen
schreiben und rechnen und es werden
jedes Jahr mehr die das nicht können
auch weil hierzulande nur 2,7 Prozent
des Bruttoinlandsprodukts in
Schulbildung fließen zum Vergleich in
Norwegen etwa sind es 4,6 in Belgien 3,9
und in Frankreich 3,3 Prozent was
Deutschland abgesehen vom Finanziellen
gerade in den Grundschulen anders machen
muss steht in einem neuen Gutachten
Stefanie Hein
was an der Grundschule gelehrt und
gelernt wird ist wichtig für das ganze
Leben doch es läuft nicht rund in den
Klassenzimmern eine Untersuchung hat
ergeben Schwächen beim Lesen Schreiben
und Rechnen hat jedes fünfte Kind und
fast so viele haben im Unterricht
Probleme zuzuhören mit gravierenden
Folgen sagen Bildungsforscher für diese
Kinder hat das die Konsequenz dass sie
dann beim Übertreten die Sekundarstufe 1
einfach nicht anschlussfähig lernen
können das heißt die Kinder werden die
nächsten sechs Jahre im Wesentlichen
weitere Schwächen Defizite kumulieren
aufbauen und werden dann am Ende der
Sekundarstufe 1 wenn sie eigentlich in
die berufliche Erstausbildung wollen
kein Ausbildungsplatz bekommen
keiner soll so früh schon den Anschluss
verlieren deshalb empfehlen
bildungsforscherinnen und Forscher der
Politik Veränderungen im
grundschulsystem danach soll Förderung
schon in der Kita beginnen und in der
Schule vor allem Deutsch und Mathematik
verstärkt vermittelt werden mit im
Durchschnitt sechs Stunden Deutsch und
fünf Stunden Mathe pro Woche es soll
regelmäßig geprüft werden ob die Kinder
Lernstandards erreichen und mehr qu
Reduzierung für pädagogisches Personal
geben wir müssen früher anfangen die
Eltern müssen mit tun die Kita hat eine
große Rolle dabei sie ist nämlich der
Ort in der dem Kinder auf die Schule
vorbereitet werden mit Blick auf ihre
Sprachfähigkeit wir müssen dafür Sorge
tragen dass Kinder wenn sie in die
Schule kommen Deutsch sprechen schnell
wird es alles nicht gehen aber der
Bildungserfolg bei den Kleinen ist
entscheidend für jedes einzelne Leben
und die ganze Gesellschaft
vermutlich erleben Sie es gerade selbst
wie viele Menschen im Moment Grippe oder
Erkältung haben einige müssen auch ins
Krankenhaus das Robert-Koch-Institut
spricht von einer außergewöhnlich hohen
Zahl von Atemwegserkrankungen Corona
spielt dabei im Moment keine große Rolle
und ausgerechnet jetzt werden
Medikamente knapp wie Fiebersaft oder
Hustenmittel vor allem für Kinder der
Grund die hohe Nachfrage trifft auf
geringes Angebot für die Pharmaindustrie
rentiert sich die Herstellung von
Arzneimitteln für Kinder in Deutschland
kaum florian korczek hat mehr guten Tag
wir hätten gerne
sie hat Glück dass in dieser Erfurter
Apotheke noch Hustensaft vorrätig ist
schlechter sieht es bei anderen
Medikamenten aus etwa Antibiotika sowie
Schmerz und fiebermitteln
Paracetamolzäpfchen gibt's schon keine
mehr bei Kindern haben wir eben die
besondere Schwierigkeit dass wir eine
sehr geringe Auswahl an Produkten haben
die sowieso auf dem Markt sind und die
Darreichungsformen für kleine Kinder zum
Beispiel sind das Zeug sind das Zäpfchen
und eventuell Säfte da können wir nicht
mit Tabletten arbeiten die angespannte
Situation zeigt sich gerade auch in
vielen Kinderarztpraxen wir versorgen
große Zahlen an Kindern pro Stunde 10
bis 15 Kinder viele Kinder sind an
RS-Virus Influenza ar-erkrankt und das
macht uns große Sorgen dass einige
Kinder schlecht mit
atemwegserweiterten Inhalation und auch
Antibiotika versorgt werden können
Kinder seien durch die Corona
kontaktbeschränkungen deutlich
infektanfälliger geworden so die Ärztin
ihre Immunsysteme sei nicht mehr so
geübt darin sich gegen Viren zu wehren
dadurch steigt zurzeit die Nachfrage
nach Medikamenten und die trifft auf ein
immer kleineres Angebot
kinderarztmittel sind in der Herstellung
teurer als Erwachsene Medikamente das
bedeutet dass in den letzten Jahren sich
Hersteller zunehmend mehr und mehr aus
diesem Markt zurückgezogen haben damit
ist natürlich die Versorgungssituation
Schwert im Falle eines akuten
versorgungsengpasses könnten Apotheker
Medikamente für Kinder selbst herstellen
indem sie etwa Erwachsenen Zäpfchen
einschmelzen und verdünnt in kleinere
Formen gießen
in Iran ist es nach der Hinrichtung
eines jungen Demonstranten zu wütenden
Protesten gekommen in Deutschland hat
das Auswärtige Amt den iranischen
Botschafter einbesteckt auf Schloss
Bellevue traf sich Bundespräsident
Steinmeier mit Vertreterinnen und
Vertretern der Deutsch iranischen
Gesellschaft die Sehnsucht nach Freiheit
lasse sich nirgendwo ersticken sagte
Steinmeier er forderte das iranische
Regime auf die Gewalt gegen frauenkinder
und Männer zu stoppen
eine neue Weltordnung entsteht gerade
auch und ganz besonders am Persischen
Golf sichtbars des Beispiel
Saudi-Arabien während die USA sich dort
immer mehr zurückziehen baut eine andere
Supermacht ihren Einfluss aus China
Präsident hier ist drei Tage auf
Staatsbesuch in Riad und beschwört die
Jahrtausende der alten Beziehungen
Elisabeth Schmidt über eine Wachablösung
es liegen Milliarden Deals auf dem Tisch
200 Mega-Projekte knapp 30 Milliarden
Dollar schwer und es geht bei weitem
nicht mehr nur um Öl Rohstoffe
Photovoltaik grüner Wasserstoff auch
Vereinbarungen mit dem chinesischen
Telekommunikationsanbieter Huawei den
die USA bislang als Sicherheitsrisiko
ablehnen
China wolle neue Möglichkeiten schaffen
für Saudi-Arabien und die anderen
Staaten sagt sie die Region neu beleben
und die Entwicklung vor Ort unterstützen
es ist erst hieß dritte Auslandsreise
seit der corona-pandemie das schmeichelt
den gastgebenden Saudis die Chinas
Machthaber einen pompösen Empfang
bereiten Fanfaren Salutschüsse
purpurfarbener Teppich
die Freundschaft zwischen Saudi-Arabien
und China ist alt ehrwürdig unser
Treffen wird unsere Zusammenarbeit
weiter stärken
ein krasser Kontrast zum Besuch des
US-Präsidenten im Juli Joe Biden ein
umstrittener Fauststoß im Wahlkampf
hatte er den saudischen Kronprinzen
wegen des Journalisten Mordes kaschocki
noch als Schurken bezeichnet die Sau die
Sonne drosselten Jungs die Ölfördermenge
reichlich diplomatische Verstimmungen
china hat gesehen dass sich da ein Raum
auftut angesichts der westlichen
Sanktionen gegen Russland wegen des
Kriegs in der Ukraine möchte Peking sich
als verlässlicher Partner im globalen
Süden positionieren China verspricht
Länder wie Saudi-Arabien auf keinen Fall
mit Sanktionen zu belegen
China präsentiert sich beim Treffen mit
den Golfstaaten als der bequemere
Verhandlungspartner es ist ein neues
Kapitel im Machtpoker mit den USA
die russische Justiz geht massiv gegen
Regime-Gegner wie ihr ja Yashin vor der
39-Jährige ist einer der wenigen
Prominenten putin-kritiker die noch im
Land geblieben sind ein Moskauer Gericht
hat den oppositionellen zu achteinhalb
Jahren Haft in einem Straflager
verurteilt weil er Falschinformationen
verbreitet habe in einem Internet-Video
hatte Ilja Jaschin den Krieg und vor
allem den Mord an Zivilisten im
ukrainischen Butcher angeprangert den
Urteilsspruch kommentierte er mit
demonstrativem lachen
der Begriff Zeitenwende ist das Wort des
Jahres der Bundeskanzler nutzte es in
einer Regierungserklärung im Februar
nach dem Überfall Russlands auf die
Ukraine
wir erleben eine Zeitenwende
und das bedeutet die Welt danach
ist nicht mehr dieselbe wie die Welt
davor
aus Sicht der Gesellschaft für deutsche
Sprache charakterisiert Zeitenwende das
Jahr 2022 am besten Krieg um Frieden und
gaspreisbremse Folgen auf Platz 2 und 3
mit selbstgebastelten Rohrbomben wollte
ein Gymnasiast ein Massaker an seiner
Schule in Essen verüben seit heute steht
der 17-Jährige vor dem Oberlandesgericht
in Düsseldorf der soll einen
rechtsextremen motivierten
Terroranschlag auf Schüler und Lehrer
geplant haben nach einem Hinweis eines
Mitschülers hatten im Mai
Spezialeinheiten die elterliche Wohnung
gestürmt dem 17-Jährigen drohen nach
Jugendstrafrecht bis zu fünf Jahre Haft
FT attraktiver schneller pünktlicher
soll die Bahn werden neue Strecken
helfen dabei haben aber ihren Preis
heute ist die neu gebaute
Schnellverbindung zwischen Wendlingen
und Ulm in Baden-Württemberg eingeweiht
worden 60 km lang die Hälfte der Strecke
führt durch neue Tunnel
Geschwindigkeiten von 250 Kilometern pro
Stunde werden so möglich die Kosten
betragen rund 4 Milliarden Euro Andreas
linke berichtet
Bahnhof Ulm Ankunft des premierenzugs an
Bord der baden-württembergische
Ministerpräsident Kretschmann und
Bahnchef Lutz mit Tempo 250 haben sie
die Strecke von Wendlingen aus
zurückgelegt
die Neubaustrecke die wir hier sehen
strahlt weit über die Region hinaus und
ist ein wirklicher Meilenstein auch in
dem was wir im Schienen jetzt in den
nächsten Jahren Vorhaben 4 Milliarden
Euro hatte neue Abschnitt gekostet er
beinhaltet spektakuläre Brücken wie die
am filztal die Reisezeit auf der Axel
München Stuttgart verkürzt sich um 15
Minuten aber so sagen Kritiker viel Geld
fließt hier nur an eine Stelle im
Bahnsystem man muss das ganze Netz vor
Augen haben und dann nutzen einem lokale
Leuchtturmprojekte und regionale
hochgeschwindigkeitstrassen nur bedingt
wir müssen das ganze Schienennetz vor
Augen haben und das ist eben sträflich
vernachlässigt worden von der
Verkehrspolitik in den vergangenen
Jahrzehnten
etwa die Hälfte der 60 km langen neuen
Strecke verläuft den Tunneln ihre
Vorteile wird sie in etwa drei Jahren
ganz ausspielen können dann soll sie mit
dem unterirdischen Bahnhofsprojekt
Stuttgart 21 verbunden sein dort über
der künftigen Halle mit ihren Lichtaugen
ist die Decke fast fertig dieser Teil
des Projekts wird aktuell mit knapp 10
Milliarden Euro veranschlagt ein
Leuchtturmprojekt das immer teurer wird
wir trauern um einen Kollegen Ruprecht
ESA ist im Alter von 79 Jahren gestorben
mehrere Jahrzehnte prägte er die
politische Berichterstattung des ZDF als
korrespondant in London oder als Gesicht
des heute-journals die Zeit nach dem
Mauerfall 1989 ein Höhepunkt seines
journalistischen Lebens wie er sagte in
seiner Sendung halb zwölf mussten sich
seine Gäste auf einen hartnäckigen
Interviewer einstellen
ein feiner Kollege jetzt zur Fußball-WM
rudi war wieder extrem spannend heute ja
der fünfmalige Weltmeister Brasilien
muss nach Hause fahren denn kroatien hat
als erste Mannschaft das Halbfinale der
Fußball-WM in Katar erreicht die hart
umkämpfte Partie endete im
Elfmeterschießen mit 4:2 nachdem es nach
der Verlängerung noch eins zu eins
gestanden hatte
mehr als 105 Minuten beißt sich
Brasilien an den Kroaten die Zähne aus
dann Doppelpass Neymar noch ein
Doppelpass Neymar das scheinbar
erlösende 1:0 für Brasilien
mit dem Rücken zur Wand spielt dann
endlich auch Kroatien nach vorne der
Schuss von Bruno Petkovic noch
abgefälscht eins zu eins
Elfmeterschießen der erste Brasilianer
dort Rodrigo und Dominik leverkowitsch
pariert schon im Achtelfinale war er der
kroatische Held der Elfmeterschießen der
insgesamt 7 Schütze misslaff auch sich
mit dem 4:2 für Kroatien damit muss
martinus treffen
Pfosten Brasilien ist raus und Kroatien
zum zweiten Mal nacheinander im
Halbfinale
und im zweiten Viertelfinale der WM
treffen um 20 Uhr den Niederlande und
Argentinien aufeinander für Bonds Coach
Louis van Hal geht es vor allem darum
Argentinien superstar Lionel Messi zu
stoppen 40.000 Fans aus Argentinien
wollen ihn heute Abend zum Sieg brüllen
und feierten schon vorher im Lucile
Stadion das aus der südamerikanischen
revivalen aus Brasilien ja und Brasilien
weint die Fußballerinnen des VfL
Wolfsburg haben das Viertelfinale der
Champions League erreicht im
Gruppenspiel gegen AS Rom siegte der VfL
mit 4:2 damit ist den Wolfsburgerinnen
die Viertelfinale nicht mehr zunehmen
rechtzeitig zur heißen Phase des
Wintersports kommt Deutschlands bester
Skispringer Karl Geiger immer besser in
Form zweieinhalb Wochen vor Beginn der
Vierschanzentournee sprang er beim
Weltcup in Titisee-Neustadt auf den
dritten Platz
Karl Geigers Erleichterung ist
offensichtlich fünftes springen erster
Podestplatz für Deutschland beim
Heimweltcup im Schwarzwald zwei starke
Sprünge der letzte auf 141,5 Meter
könnten die Initialzündung für einen
erfolgreichen Winter sein jetzt ist der
Weg ziemlich klar und es wird jetzt mal
besser mal schlechter gehen aber so wie
heute da also ich komme aus
abgerundet wird das Gesamtergebnis durch
den siebten Platz von Konstantin Schmidt
es gewinnt Einzel lani-check aus
Slowenien vor dem Polen David Kubatzki
und einem hochzufriedenen Karl Geiger
Justus Strehlow ist beim Biathlon
Weltcup in Hochfilzen im Sprint auf
Platz 9 gelaufen und hat damit das
bisher beste Ergebnis seiner Karriere
erzielt der 25-Jährige blieb über die
zehn Kilometer fehlerfrei im Schießen
und erfüllt damit auch die WM-Norm den
Sieg sicherte sich erneut Johannes Böh
aus Norwegen sein 55 Weltcup Erfolg na
bravo Wintersport morgen 10:10 Uhr
geht's los kann man sich gut merken aber
auf jeden Fall danke schön das wird ein
winterlicher Dritter Advent häufig
frostig glatt und auch mit etwas neu
Schnee Details gleich von Katja hahnefer
das heute journal um 10 mit Marietta
Slomka hier übernimmt morgen wieder mit
Siri wir danken und sagen tschüss und
wünschen Ihnen ein schönes
Adventswochenende auf bald
[Musik]
guten Abend von Süden kommt der Schnee
es hat ja schon heute geschneit zum
Beispiel auf der Schwäbischen Alb und
weitere Schneefälle sind im Anzug auch
heute Nacht wird es noch schneien zum
Beispiel Thüringer Wald oder auch im
Schwarzwald es kann überall glatt sein
auf den Straßen nicht nur dort wo sich
wenn es aufklappt mal Nebel bildet denn
die Temperaturen sinken auf 0 bis -5
Grad und über den Schneeflächen direkt
am Boden wird sogar noch kälter da gehen
die Temperaturen auf -10° zurück und die
Höchsttemperaturen morgen liegen um den
Gefrierpunkt das Wetter dabei ist drei
geteilt im Norden Nordosten bleibt es
trüb etwas Sonne kommt vielleicht
zwischen dem Sauerland und der Eifel
heraus und die Schneewolken aus den
Alpen ziehen weiter nordwärts direkt am
Alpenrand können innerhalb von 12
Stunden an die 10 cm Neuschnee
zusammenkommen sonst werden es wohl nur
wenige Zentimeter sein und dieser Schnee
zieht am Sonntag am 3 Advent dann weiter
Nord ostwärts dann schneit es jetzt zum
Beispiel im Erzgebirge und auch an der
Ostseeküste sind einige die Regenschauer
zu erwarten sonst kommt aber am Sonntag
häufiger mal die Sonne zum Vorschein und
bei den Temperaturen ändert sich wenig
bis bald